opportunities away from their kids to grow in a game
I just got home from the gym and I saw that video
and I wanna weigh in as a family that does not prioritize sport
because I think the original creator
no hate to him whatsoever
this is a really interesting conversation
I think that creator thinks that parents that don't prioritize their kids sports
or travel sports
are doing so to prioritize themselves
but in reality
at least for my family
I know that it's because we're prioritizing our family time
and I know that we're the aberration in our area
suburban America
I see more families that prioritize multiple sports
and taking their kids to and from activities
than I see family sitting down for family dinner
I also see more parents living vicariously through their children's
athletic aptitude
than I do otherwise
daddy played football
so Timmy's gotta play football
and don't get me wrong
you learn lots of great camaraderie teamwork perseverance
determination through sports
but you can also learn those other ways
I think what our family is at least trying to do
is find a balance between fostering our kids talents and interests
and having a close bond as a family
and I think travel sports can really put a diaper on that
and don't get me wrong
if I had a kid that was Wayne Gretzky and wanted to be on the ice 24 7
we would be a travel hockey family
I remember reading a quote from Tom Brady
I think it was
who said nobody ever had to make him practice
but the reality is
I just don't think it's that big of a deal
most kids who play wreck sports aren't gonna go on to the collegiate level
or even the professional level
it's all for fun
and for fostering those skills that you get from a team sport activity
but there's a balance
and I know in our area there is not as much balance as I think there should be
kids sports have become way too competitive and way too intense
let the kids have fun
sure absolutely
pick a sport try all the sports
we've tried like
I think a thousand sports at this point
but don't forget that free time and time with just their family to hang out
go on vacation
go camping have dinner at home
those are also good things for kids too